welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm grace Helbig your host we have
GG gorgeous back with us today and it's
a gorgeous day in the neighborhood
because this episode we talked about her
new makeup line with Ipsy we talked
about what it's like to be a wifey we
talked about how she sleep kicks her
wife we talked about her wedding we
talked about Oh guys scandal at the
wedding Lady Gaga's ex showed up and he
wanted a chicken breast I'll just leave
it at that
listen and enjoy this episode not too
deep with Gigi gorgeous have you ever
heard of lab-grown diamonds well
lab-grown diamonds are essentially
chemically identical to natural ones
just made in a lab at lightbox they've
cracked the science to grow gorgeous
stones every time so check them out at
lightbox jewelry dot-com / Grace and use
the code grace for $25 off I'm so
excited that you're back me too how are
you I'm good thanks for having me and
thank you for being here you're a
married woman now I'm married yeah what
has anything changed I mean your
significant others literally sitting
right oh no I just watched this morning
that's getting your makeup done by you
and I heard a joke about like the thing
that you care more the best accessories
yeah and then I pull out away which is
like my next accessory which I'm not I'm
song's wig yeah honestly I feel like I
just feel more comfortable but yeah I
feel like when we got engaged everyone's
like oh my god how does it feel to be a
fiance yeah and I'm just like I don't
know I feel more secure what was the
timeline of everything so how long was
it from when you got engaged to when you
got married it was over a year over you
which I feel like people should do
people rush in so far yeah like engaged
30 days later they're getting married
it's like
where's that like a TV reality show Yeah
right like want a deadline people we
have cameras it's not but okay I want to
talk a little bit when the wedding was
absolutely beautiful and thank you so
much for having me as a guest it was
like incredibly lovely and cried
multiple times
Sam well yeah what was it like for you
guys planning it I mean it must have
been the most chaotic thing ever it's
crazy it's literally like I mean not to
like
compare it to a birthday party but it's
like the big celebration is heads like
down to every detail I had never really
planned anything in that into is never
planned a wedding before although now I
know all the ins and outs so anyone
getting married I'm like ask me yeah I
did it I feel like you have another
career route as a wedding planner oh
yeah I would be so down yeah like
calling all the shots being such a [ __ ]
and I think the main tip I would say is
get a wedding planner because like yeah
wedding planner Mindy Weiss like handled
on everything also save your money
because it's [ __ ] expensive yeah what
is there one thing that you look back
and go we didn't need to do that I mean
probably like a list of ten things I was
pretty over the top but I will say to
you guys also had a very sweet like I
will say like a humble loving like it
was all focused on your energy and your
love for each other
five hundred people wasn't this like big
pomp and circumstance about it it was
just very very sweet and so yeah that's
I wonder like what was the thing that
you look back and go we could have cut
corners there I don't know honestly I
feel like going back I just was so happy
seeing everything I can talk about it
for months and months and it's like oh
my god the flowers actually look pissed
oh you're gonna blur the day up yeah
you're yet you're in like tunnel vision
of like where am I going Who am I saying
hi to you what am i doing exactly and
then it's like where's my wife important
thing it's like you do you talk to each
other then you're in trouble
oh I loved you and your father's dance
was the sweetest thing there's like the
first time we ever danced in my life
really yes I was so nervous I was like
is he gonna touch my head like is it
gonna be weird you need to have a talk
before no we didn't do anything and I
wanted to practice but it was just so
chaotic so he didn't so
he grabbed my hand I was like carry
nothing back and everyone has their
cameras out and I was like oh God
and I like at one point I don't know if
this is in the video but at one point I
got awkward because I was like okay
there's so much of the song left but
it's sweet I'm loving it but there's so
much left so I was like I took his hand
away and like spun around him and like a
ballerina like shuffle well then I was
like okay what am i doing go back it was
a very chaotic moment in my head it's
actually a very real moment too because
when you think about like first dance
and like you know the parents dance
mm-hmm songs are like 3 to 4 minutes
we're in this internet culture of like
our timespan of like a tension is like a
maximum one minute yeah I got to the
first chorus oh yeah like oh we're gonna
keep going is that the extended cut no
but it was really sweet honestly I like
wouldn't change the thing I like even
did a couple dips he caught dad you
killed it but you're strong
has there been since you guys have had
your wedding has there been a wedding
that you've been to like do you go to
weddings now and look around and like
can kind of assess what's going on I
wish I really wish I really went to one
wedding together which was in her family
in London yeah which was fabulous
and the only other wedding I've ever
been to was my dad's and I was in it
that's the only other wedding yes or
your own wedding you've never been to
uh-huh Wow I know and I'm like I want to
go to more weddings I just want a party
I don't want to plan yeah start coupling
people up and make them get married as
we get older it's good just gonna happen
hopefully fingers crossed I went down
there slap face did you guys honeymoon
we didn't know we're putting that off to
work when he came in we have a lot in
mind I feel like it's gonna be one of
those things where it's not one
destination it's like a bunch of things
we want to do you guys travel like crazy
to begin with yeah and so like I wonder
where you could go that would be super
special for you so we're new I feel
somewhere that both of you haven't been
before I kind of want that gallery you
said one stop on the trip so it's like
we're experiencing it having fun and if
you hate it you go to someplace that
you've been before
we know this one yeah I feel like it's
so fun to spread it out I mean I broke
Matt's his knee like this is not a
metaphor this is a real thing like
full-on yeah she was bouncing me on her
knee and I like salad with in my entire
body way my fat body on her help me yes
right before the wedding and we're like
doing postpone the wedding
like it was a madman Akane okay I
understand everything now this just came
from a simple moment of you doing like a
Santa Clause nothing sexual it was
nothing crazy we were lit I was
literally sitting on her knee she was
bouncing me and then just [ __ ] went
crazy and she was gonna get surgery so
we're like let's put the surgery off so
kind of worked out yeah happy because
it's like you kind of have something to
look forward to
yep ik Journey we're about to go on you
know yeah and also I mean it's also a
very hilarious story because it's one of
those that you're like I wish this was
scandalous I wish that there was
something more here but I literally just
sat on my wife and broke her it's like
our martyrs anything I'm like really
right before the wedding but the cane
looked dope and that's was a trooper
about it so it's all good oh that's
amazing
yeah okay let's talk if see the GG
gorgeous they make a collection yes this
is incredible you sent me a package it's
absolutely beautiful
literally the other night I was with my
boyfriend Elliot and he just I just hear
him go this is incredible and I look
over and he's just wiping your brushes
all over it they're so it's beautiful
how long has this been in the works
right now um it's been in the works for
over a year okay and it's like crazy cuz
everything takes so long yeah just every
we've heard about developing anything
but I just was like okay I'm gonna go in
this like you know my first time first
impressions I'm like I'm gonna use
products that I know yeah so I made
products that I love but I know that
other people will love they're very
representative of you yeah you like I
feel like whenever I get like a person's
makeup product or like a book I'm like I
have a little piece of them yeah so it's
like if it's sitting on someone's vanity
or in someone's purse I want them to be
like this is like a GG product
you know GG approved hmmn I love that
feeling because people are like oh I
love the blush it just makes me feel
like there's a piece of you on me and
I'm like yes this is exactly why I did
this even the packaging like the white
and the gold and everything is very very
very beautiful what does like what does
that look like behind the scene it's
like how intense is that I mean I have
no understanding of that world I was
lucky enough that the laboratories and
everything was in LA mm-hmm so I could
go see it in real life but for the most
part it's mostly like digital images
I think we're getting samples you're
like okay this gold foiling is not cute
this material is not cute actually no
there's like a layer it's like
everything is just hand-picked and so
intense but I was lucky that if she
already had all of that under their belt
okay so it was like yeah you just like
nitpick the fine things and also we'll
create the formula so it wasn't like me
going to a random laboratory by myself
right I felt secure and it's
cruelty-free
it's vegan yeah yeah all the important
stuff and also like I wanted to keep it
really affordable yeah nobody has like
you know all the money in the world just
that's the for money yeah I mean it's
crazy so I feel like sometimes products
I'm like really it's gorge but you could
get something today I'd wanted to make
it kill but that's also I liked when I
watched your video with Nets of you
giving her a makeover that you're using
like L'Oreal foundation and like you're
doing high-end drugstore and that's all
about yeah nobody's got time for all
high-end all the time well that's what I
love about you in general is that you've
stayed very true to your roots of like
being a very real person being very like
transparent being very like this is who
I am I'm I think it or leave it I'm
gorgeous but also like I literally was
looking your Instagram account you're
like fart but make it fashion and it
killed me yeah that's like that's
exactly your brand no offense I love it
I mean it's just a realness everybody
farts yeah that is true so what so what
happens now after this like line has
been dropped her collection is that what
you call it a collection yeah so it's
like the first collection I'm just
honestly like thriving off of it it's
the first of possibly many possibly yeah
I mean I don't want to say anything just
yet sure obviously but it manifested
manovich yeah
I mean honestly the feedback has been
fab if C's were super happy and yeah
just living my married life and seeing
everybody to get the makeup and try it
no that must be so wonderful it's crazy
I feel like when I watch like makeup
tutorials where people like snapping me
yeah yeah or like even just applying it
I'm like is that a fake pot like do they
actually have it but there's also like
from what I say Glee understand about
the makeup industry there's so much
scrutiny there's so much criticism and
there's so much like
people are ready to rip apart your
product like was that in your brain
about launching this 100% I feel like
honestly any industry but especially
Beauty right now yeah I've really blown
up and I'm more saturated I feel like
they really are gonna nitpick anything
yeah I'm happy with it like just like if
I put out a video and it's like you know
people are always going to say something
cruel or is gonna have something to say
like oh that's cultural appropriation or
that's rude or this is disgusting or not
high-quality whatever it's like
everyone's gonna have something to say
but if you're happy with it at the end
of the day it's like you can speak to it
yeah and also it's just it makes you
proud so it's like if they don't like it
then don't buy it that's your next
tagline for your next show 5 you don't
like it don't buy it what do you do do
ya okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back I have more questions
for you and then we have a bunch of
Twitter questions hell yeah do this so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
two deep native creates safe simple
effective products that people use every
day their products are filled with
trusted ingredients and their natural
deodorant is no different native
deodorant is formulated without aluminum
without parabens without talc and with
ingredients found in nature like coconut
oil shea butter and tapioca starch whoa
very cool their formula contains simple
ingredients you understand and comes in
a wide variety of enticing sense for men
and women plus they released new limited
edition seasonal scents throughout the
year
they're classic deodorant scents include
coconut and vanilla lavender and rose
you come Burum in eucalyptus and mint
making the switch to a natural deodorant
does not mean having to sacrifice an
odor or witness-protection native is the
proof there's a reason why they have
over 9,000 five-star reviews there's
also a notice to try it
native offers free shipping and free
returns and exchanges in the USA I
currently have the lavender and rose and
I will currently tell you it is helping
me immensely as someone that you
probably know hates hygiene all around
the board it's truly a miraculous
wonderful gift and now you get 20% off
your first purchase when you visit
native deodorant calm and use the promo
code grace during checkout that's native
deodorant calm promo code grace for 20%
off your first purchase Dave the
creators of clean Beauty bare minerals
is driven by a philosophy that makeup
and skin care should make your skin
better not just better looking what
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients guess what they're all
minerals for bare minerals to be clean
without compromise means good for skin
formulas with proven performance so
upgrade to clean beauty products use
their foundation finder at bare minerals
calm and find your perfect match and get
20% off when you use the promo code not
too deep bare minerals the power of good
okay we're back in where can people I
mean I I got this magical box sent to my
doorstep so where can people that don't
have the luxury of having that happen
get this line from you you can get it on
if c-calm okay exclusively but if you
have a membership with them they do glam
bags every month oh yeah they do the
glam bag the glam bag plus and the glam
bag ultimate and then the products will
go in that and they have like millions
of subscribers so people are already
getting it but if you want to shop
uniquely like single products yeah just
go to FC dot-com have you is there a
product that you have in your dream
dreams would want to develop um whether
it be makeup whether it be fashion
whether it be lifestyle whether it be in
you know a dog a dog for sure you know
what I would actually love to speaking
of animals I would love to create a
kitten that let you cuddle it all the
time pillow yeah that has like a little
voice box in it that purrs I feel like I
wouldn't leave bed like I'm cuddling
babe sorry no I feel like honestly
anything to make like my trans community
my fellow brothers and sisters like feel
more comfortable yeah many products like
that because for myself like I had to
literally go through so many trials and
tribulations of products that worked for
me um you know clothing that worked and
just anything I mean I feel like people
they're a lot more educated now but
anything to make their lives easier
well that that leads into like the other
thing I wanted to ask you about is
you're like we talked about earlier you
have this JIT like very amazing
authenticity to who you are but you also
have put yourself in front of a camera
for years and have let people like in on
your journey of growth and etc where do
you or do you feel the stress of like
putting yourself out there completely
I mean you've written your your memoir
you've had your documentary you really
constantly and I just saw it like the
the you know hair video like they're yes
I'm still healing
actually hey should I wear waiting man
but it's amazing how like casually you
seem to put yourself out there do you
feel does that stress you out do you
feel like an obligation have to do that
it's stressful
I mean honestly I'd be lying if I said
it wasn't right it's like it's big
things yeah I think about it's not
casual like here's this makeup he's
talking about it's like really life
things but I feel like it's strategic in
a way where I think about it for so long
that it's like okay I'm comfortable with
it and like I'm finally ready to talk
about it because also like the worst
feeling and I know you know this is when
you make a video and you go back and
you're like I wish I had said and like
more yeah I was like I had more well
thought out you know so I feel like when
I'm ready to talk about it when it's out
there I'm comfortable and I'm ready but
it's a process yeah because how long
have you been making YouTube videos a
decade a decade it switches so makes me
feel so old
right I know but so we're in the same
boat like and watching your videos has
your because I know my like relationship
with making videos has changed
dramatically and it's constantly
changing do you feel exhausted so much
okay thank you but the thing is like you
have to give yourself time right I feel
like that's just with anything like if
you're exhausted then literally just
take like a little break yeah but for me
like my mind is so I feel fast-paced and
I'm so impatient yeah that my like
downtime is literally like one or two
days and then I'm bailing let's get back
into it
do you and nuts have a safe word or some
sort of boundary set up of how much you
will actually put on the internet versus
what's know there's really everything's
out there yeah but it's also like a
mutual it's not like anything crazy we
yeah yeah but I feel like if if
something is like no show literally just
rate up you like know usually yes what
are their upcoming videos already
planned already shot already ready to go
yeah I've actually been really good
recently then yeah I've been stockpiled
stockpiling videos yeah good for you I
do that and I feel so good it feels
really nice to like do [ __ ] that you
like yeah like I can't wait for the
world to see this like I literally just
post I actually saw you liked it on the
way over here yeah the jeffree star Tran
formation video mm-hmm I love him so
much yeah and my friend is so great at
transformation so I was really excited
about this one because I look so much
[ __ ] like Geoffrey star in the video
it's incredible it's crazy
very cool I didn't want to take it off
I'm like how have you seen YouTube
changed since you started I feel like
it's a much I don't want to say meaner
place but like it's so much more
nitpicky yeah you know and it can get
you down like I feel like anybody's
starting now has it really hard because
of the amount of people who are on it
obviously mm-hmm but at the same time
it's like everyone has something to say
and we all know the Internet is like can
be super cruel yeah and people say
things that they would never in real
life so having more people online is
also a little bit scarier because that's
like more people on you more on voices
at you mm-hmm and I feel like it's just
it's become a lot more savage yeah it
has everyone's very excited to be angry
and happy for people and it yeah you
can't do any my feelings of that but you
cannot do anything right anything like
just sit there and blink for two minutes
that's a great video yeah I feel like
you just got to do you though I mean
everyone's gonna be offended in mad yeah
how um one your Halloween costume is
just to go back a little bit we're
incredible thanks Sally and Jack
Skellington yeah you guys dress up I
feel like all year round but is
Halloween a big thing for you it is but
can I tell you I'm so [ __ ] happy it's
over expectation for you guys know
everything came together literally
within one week and we dressed up so
much it's just so many parties yeah
exhausting so I'm just happy I mean
honestly I love Halloween I think more
than nuts does although Jack Skellington
is very like holding your bag just
shrugging show yeah sure I feel like all
of our friends are like oh I don't want
to dress up it's like I feel like we
kind of have to live it up for you yeah
but yeah it was fine I'm just happy it's
over did you dresses anything uh what I
do I dressed as a hoagie
yeah Oh everything yeah hungry yeah it's
very New Jersey appropriate
yeah I love a good hoagie home town or
home state rather what do you take me
through like a normal day for you
it's app I mean it depends on what state
let's say this is a day off that you
have what do you do with a day off okay
well I just found out this really good
trick and I feel like everyone should
know it okay so in the morning wash my
face oh my god I've been working out
actually to work out work out like what
are you still shaking from this morning
wild but anything that this eye cream
trick is something so major if you put
on your eye serum you put on your eye
cream and you don't have that just get
whatever good and then you know those
like jelly pad yeah you put that over
like a thick layer of that stuff and
that keeps it on it like penetrates
deeper well so I've been doing that and
literally when you take it off I'm
telling you it like puffs out your eyes
and makeup look so pretty underneath
let's see that those little alien like I
like pads underneath I can never they
fall off my face that I feel like one it
makes me look like this pretentious
[ __ ] that my Chin's just raised they
keep it on my face as I walk down my
house like making coffee but that's good
to know
yeah there's Dom I feel like this serum
makes it stick [ __ ] okay it like sticks
to it but then when it starts getting
dry like 10-15 minutes later take it off
and it really makes a big difference
all right okay so after you do your full
face routine yes what do you do to relax
I mean I've been loving nine-one-one
recently oh I was like prank-calling
right after my skin pear calling them
and letting them know that my eyes feel
great I just like calling them I'm not
saying anything hi I have an emergency
my skin is hydrated my skin looks gorge
everyone loving that show honestly TV is
like I'm addicted right yeah what are
you watching other than 911 Real
Housewives of New York yeah wait obsess
I love all Bravo omega-t telling me what
you're talking about Vanderpump rules
outside our house
I'm so excited I was just like can we
get Stassi back on the podcast yeah
she's an engaged woman now and I want to
know everything about it yes
yeah I'm obsessed I've never met Lisa
Vanderpump have you yes I met oh my god
this is such an embarrassing story yeah
so we were at pump okay and my best
friend at the time and this is like when
facetune had like just come out it was
like in our brains at all times like oh
that what it would look great but I
would change this yeah and it was like
just wild so photo like basically we're
Picasa so we see Lisa at pump and we're
like should we go ask for a photo like
this is so major yeah we go get our
photo and we face tuned it to the ground
like yeah with her in it and we face
tuned her too I really want to pull up
the photo but it's so long ago it was
humiliating like we both look like
aliens I don't even look like us when
you think you're being so sneaky -
you're like no one's gonna know this has
been touched up it oh no wall is warped
in the background Lisa doesn't even look
as she looks like Kyle Richards like it
was crazy at the time so you're obsessed
with New York you got your favorite of
all the franchises yeah I think honestly
Beverly Hills has gotten a bit boring to
be honest yeah it's just too much that
dog scenario did you watch last season I
did that's just every episode was about
this dog so I love that dorita accent
changes every episode me too I kind of
like idolized her a little bit sure I
mean she's from Connecticut and she
talks like she's from Wales or so what
is this Boston London hybrid that you
know she's and piqué piqué Jack what's a
spaceman same musician that's just in
the background ah Boy George hey Joel
yeah it just happens to be like hanging
out eating like Triscuits in their
kitchen yeah her other kid is invisible
there's only Jagger shaaka Jack garlic
who lets the other kids name
oh it's fantastic I love it I love every
hairstyle she wears no and how
everything is so branded like Chanel
Gucci like okay we got it
I love it me more of it it's fine
is there a reality show that you would
be a part of okay I know you've done
your documentary which is basically a
reality television kind of but not
because I feel like reality they like
build you up to tear you down yeah or
they just [ __ ] up your whole life right
they're looking for every avenue to make
you seem more like yeah in quote
interesting exactly let us end yeah I
feel like the people on like Vanderpump
rules for example are so good at like
fighting yeah like they're just good at
it well that I talked to Stassi and she
was like yeah the producer just takes us
out to like drinks before the season
starts and basically like gets us [ __ ]
up and then like asked like would of
your relationships been with everyone
and then that's how they manage like the
whole season and then they are drinking
like on camera and then they're probably
like you know what like let's just turn
it out like let's just fight okay like
go for it I also that's one of the
things that kind of bums me out
sometimes is when you realize that they
know what their narrative is like when
they're trying to like I'm mad at you
yeah don't forget don't forget yeah now
she kind of like her would you and knots
ever be on The Amazing Race together ooh
a good question you know what we were
actually we were actually we were asked
to be on Fear Factor and I wanted to do
it but she is such she's such a fear of
spiders
oh yeah no I couldn't do that so she
literally said no and I was like once in
a lifetime but I feel like there it
would be something to do with like
insects and nasty [ __ ] see that's all
you need to do is say that once and then
the producers know and they're gonna
make that the actual challenge for you
yes and like even visually seeing them
Oh rocket Bob uh yeah but yeah Amazing
Race is kind of like I don't know I feel
like we would just be like wait can we
call our travel agent you don't have a
phone yeah give me here [ __ ] yeah
there's 20 bucks
that was your food stipend you're like I
bought a cell phone yeah in Zimbabwe
would you do Big Brother
I love Big Brother okay I feel like no
okay just they always being on camera
freaks me out
the fact that they have the 24-hour like
livestream off camera like the main
programming freaks me out and also like
you know when you're like in a bathing
suit or taking a shower you have to wear
that necklace Mike oh yeah I'm so bad at
stuff like that like I don't want to
wear that like throwing because they say
to you I've heard like friends that have
that are on the show if you're not
wearing it they're like Gigi put on your
microphone really like throughout the
whole house oh dang everyone would be
like she's not obeying the rules oh
you're in a bad light that way yeah yeah
would you guys ever do a reality show
about your like keeping up with the
Kardashian it's just about your everyday
life we were pitched like several times
before we got married after we got
married and really just like is this
worth it like right now having so much
control over like what goes out there
and already like sharing so much it's
right is nothing gonna be sacred anymore
well that's what I mean like you you
guys have put everything out there that
like at some point you have to have
something for yourselves yeah and I feel
like right now we have a good amount
yeah it's like you know on our days off
it's like Oh cameras are coming over oh
my god I feel like can I quit now how
many people are in your house on a
regular basis probably around five
everyday yeah
Wow yeah all kind of just the two of you
yes Wow yeah we were like people people
yeah you're not reclusive yeah I mean we
can be but I mean including our kitties
that's like seven people he's our baby
okay can you talk us through briefly
your friendship journey with Paris
Hilton oh my God he's guys I was just
watching a video of her actually yeah
where I mean had Harrises fab first of
all yeah I've heard great things about
you
you ever met her I've never met her but
I can remember now yeah I love her so
much um yeah I mean I don't even really
remember where we met to be oh I met her
actually you know beautycon yes I met
her at a beautycon dinner okay yeah and
we kind of like hit it off super cool
super chill I was with my sister
she was with her cousin so it was kind
of like a little family moment yeah and
it was really fun she's just really nice
she's kind of everything that you would
think she was yeah you know when you
meet like your idol or like just someone
that you've known forever and you're
kind of like oh [ __ ] I wish I didn't
meet that person yeah don't meet your
heroes exactly so I'm like I'm really
happy that she's kind of like the same
she's exactly how you imagined yeah yeah
yeah I'm not disappointed at all that's
amazing yeah and I feel like a lot of
people say that about her so good but
yeah we celebrated my birthday last year
in New York apartment it was like this
beautycon thing again but it was so much
fun
I feel like partying with her is like
super I mean I must be kind of stressful
for her to have this legacy of being
like the party queen that you're like
I'm gonna celebrate my birthday with
Paris Hilton like expectations are high
I got that I mean but when you're an
icon it just work I mean she's truly a
legend I love her and also she just
hasn't aged at all
she looks so beautiful yeah she looks
exactly the same
I feel like she does have a sense of
humor about her own brand absolutely and
that's something that I need yeah I too
seriously too much ego too much like
narcissism it's just like get me the
[ __ ] yeah she is a really really good
heart I mean that's an reality show to
pitch everyone bull life to a more
simple life okay have you ever had
anyone from your story times reach out
to you after the story time videos ooh
good question I'm sure you're like I
don't respond to my D no I feel like I
used to make story times about like
friends or like just random people I'd
had experiences with uh-huh and like
still had their numbers so I'm sure but
I don't really I can't imagine no that's
good I'm I think that's the best-case
scenario over here
like yes this person okay okay we're
gonna take one last break when we get
back we have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you always I'm very
excited back so we'll be right back with
more not too deep is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help online counseling can help
they offer licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in issues
like depression anxiety relationships
trauma anger family conflicts lgbtq+
matters grief self-esteem and more
connect with your professional counselor
in a safe and private online environment
get the help at your own time at your
own pace anything you share is
confidential it's convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and if for some reason you're
not happy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time for no
additional charge and best of all it's
an affordable option and you will get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace go to better help
calm slash grace fill out the
questionnaire that helps them assess
your needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you will love today
that's better help calm such grace
high-and-mighty is putting hanging into
your hands hanging can be overwhelming
and the second you have to get out a
tool it's a brand new project so your
favorite art gets left on the ground and
floating shelves are bought but never
put up you know me you've seen my
youtube videos I've tried to hang
shelves it does not work out but this is
a wonderful solution lose the anxiety
with high m.i.t you can hang without
needing a single tool you just place
push and hang and it's up they offer
strong and easy to install hanging
products including wall hangers
decorative hooks and floating shelves
their hangers hold up to a hundred and
twenty-five pounds it's like a gymnast
so there's no such thing as something
too heavy to hang floating shelves come
with their own level and install in
minutes I've been sent these shelves
I've been sent these decorative hooks
they are beautiful they are easy you
just
literally push the I me if you have you
know anxiety and about hanging just
literally push it into this hanging
situation find out where you can get the
full line of products and watch the how
to videos at designed to be stuck up
calm / grace again that's designed to be
stuck up calm / grace okay we're back
before we get into our Twitter questions
I'm going to ask you the two questions
asked every single guest that is on the
podcast and you've answered these in the
past but I do not remember what your
answers were so everything will be a new
answer okay who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
I thought I was gonna be like go to
dinner with thinking about all my heroes
idols that had to go the other way kind
of the same thing I really feel like
right now just off the top of my head
I'm gonna treat this as like a fire
question turn around I'm Donald Trump
yeah truly I mean his knees already kind
of looks like it has spaghetti on it
yeah but he just is like not a good man
truly truly okay the other question I
ask every single guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or a
close call but you can only use three
words or small phrases so mine
classically is college jogging front
lawn amazing did you not make it now I
made it on alone so your close call or
worse story but you can only use three
words or three small phrase you know
what is so funny and we have to look
this up uh-huh I think I said the same
thing last time okay girlfriend at the
time bad middle of the night yeah yeah
I remember yeah that's down in history
moment but now you get a new one goes
you're married you gotta [ __ ] again yeah
get those plastic sheets ready okay
before we're getting these Twitter
questions you hit people while you sleep
is a thing right yes what do you dream
do you know what you're dreaming about
what is that question it is a question
because I forgot that I wanted to ask
this earlier that is I do I do it's a
big problem
I sleep talk IQ sleep talk do you say
like actual sentences or is it just kind
of like mumbo-jumbo okay it's real
sentences but is it though because every
single time I've asked it's like I can't
remember
is it any have you nets have you ever
heard her say any like thing that's very
like revealing like yeah like my inner
truth my truth asleep yeah like all I
think one time well one time I think you
said like oh the makeup is off or
something like I was thinking of getting
glam or something but yeah I rarely ever
dream like I rarely rarely dream you
know I mean I do but I'll forget it
within the first like ten minutes of
waking up okay so I don't know what I'm
doing it in there but you're getting
agitated about it yeah like I only kick
and thrash always literally since I was
young I really yeah so I would always
get my own bed which is nice like I'll
kick you you don't want this it happens
is the thing wow that's so fascinating
it's not so I'm like what are you what
where's your brain go and and also you
don't need to workout if you're getting
your workout I just wake up profusely
sweating you know what I want to do
action for a video because of that
that's when you bring that up I want to
go to like a sleep doctor and have them
hook me up and like have me full film
yeah and have him analyze me did that
really yeah she did like the 24 hour
like sleep analysis where you have to
like stay awake every hour it's very
like regimented if you feel like a
little hamster and like yeah yeah for
sure yeah you feel like Milly Bobby
Brown okay let's get into this Twitter
question
and someone snow what was your favorite
part of your wedding um when I saw gnats
at the end of the altar oh yeah because
you guys did you didn't know what each
other were wearing you had kept it a
complete secret it was like a true
actual moment for you guys yeah that was
definitely my like most shocking moment
where I first cuz I was like I'm not
gonna cry it's not gonna happen like I
just won't feel it but during the vows I
was crying the whole time
oh and that train that ran through yeah
kind of the most perfect thing I must
sentimental part of my vows and then
this train comes by it's like this old
train stop and they assured us that that
wouldn't happen oh it was kind of the
perfect and most like on-brand relief at
this moment and I was like I gotta get
myself together and then when it finally
went by I was like hey guys we're
getting back into yeah that I wouldn't
change for the world but at the time I
was like it's ruined
were there any behind the scenes like
scrambles or like ridiculous moments
from the wedding because you guys seem
like you were coasting on just like
happiness the entire time it was that
but also so one of Nazis bridesmaids hmm
actually hooked up with Lady Gaga's ex
okay and I made a video about this okay
he actually reached out to me for the
wedding
um no at the wedding anyway he ended up
sitting at our like table with us like
full with all of our bridal party and
I'm like who is this man turns out is
this guy named Christian okay and he was
engaged to Lady gaga and yeah i was just
gagged i was like oh my god this is like
wedding [ __ ] that you hear about
happen i couldn't make this [ __ ] up it's
amazing and also you handled it
beautifully
no one knew yeah one of my um one of my
bridesmaids chicken from the dinner
I'm like how ballsy can you guys know I
love it I'm like okay Wow wedding
crasher I probably would have done the
same thing
what an ideal wedding dress it's funny I
was like I know that face right I didn't
like how can i play was gonna be said
Wow
can I get your chicken yeah all right
literally okay someone's no why does
milk in Canada come in bags I don't know
even the thought of that I ate so much
cheese yesterday [ __ ] like I chose
intolerance I mean yeah the one what
this is like one of my most wonderful
things that's ever happened to me in
your presence is that my ex-boyfriend
when we were at a convention in
Australia was eating like subway seafood
sensations like crazy because they're
only available like in Australia and we
were at a bar you me and memory and him
and he farted the grossest fart that
I've ever experienced in my life
and you just you took a tequila shot and
then you looked at him you go that's a
lactose mamrie and I still laugh about
that constantly doing somersaults over
on my back going through her legs that's
something that will inevitably happen I
feel like with that woman in my life
she's gonna go there you got I just want
that's maybe the reality show I want to
watch is you guys going away for a
weekend just doing anything would be the
most fine it would be very what's the
drink today yeah and then we just let
the day happen oh I would love it she's
so much fun
someone's no how many dresses did you
try on before landing on your wedding
dress um well I made them all custom
from Michael Costello who is a fabulous
friend and he just is like the dream
wedding designer honestly in my eyes
yeah it just makes everyone feel so
feminine and all of his visions are so
like modern yet classic which is what I
wanted so I tried on like a little base
dress okay just to like get the fabric
at the color and then literally went
from there so basically only one did you
go in with a fully-formed idea what you
wanted yeah I made like a mood board I
wore dresses and I was like is he gonna
be offended if I bring in like other
designers wedding dresses he wasn't and
he just was like I see this for you like
let's do it and it was the longest
wedding dress that he
ever worked on because really meeting
and everything was like imported Wow so
I was like wow I feel super honored
that's very special
I'm just custom is like okay no one else
is gonna be me on my wedding day yeah
the good feeling it's your day you can
uniquely make it yours and that's so
cool
someone's no Slurpee or big gulp wine
so let's no do you wear anything more
than once how big is your closet my
closets pretty big but yeah I mean even
what I'm wearing right now this is like
my favorite little crop top
I definitely wear stuff twice yeah or
like three or ten times how's married
life
thinking of expanding the family Holly
is thinking of expanding the family not
to actually came up with a really good
kid name yesterday really yeah which
obviously is like top secret cuz I let
out the last one she was like that was
our baby name like oh I thought it was
just a contender she's like still how
many kids ideally I want I grew up with
two brothers right no like total of
three I feel like three would be fab
okay but I could see us having more to
be honest just a whole gaggle yeah yeah
I feel like I expand the family let's
make a Kardashian mom out of it yeah
more pets yeah yeah what are your
favorite makeup products right now other
than your own I'm in my own yes yes yes
one hug it's a um I've I mean I love
k'kaw beauty oh really yes and I think a
kW I mean honestly almost anything of
her brand is really amazing well I've
been wearing a lot of that obviously
jeffree star and Shane Dawson's recent
cloud the conspiracy palette fabulous
yeah I think those are too oh and Tati
Beauty you know talk to you here on you
yeah yeah she should take a lunch right
yeah and her eyeshadow palette is
amazing
it might do when you launched your or
have since you've launched yours did you
know that everyone else was kind of
launching at the same time like or is
it's just kind of the thing that you're
like oh shoot like are there seasons for
this I feel like now it's honestly like
every month you can have some
whether it's from Rihanna k'kaw Jeffrey
Tati like just everybody I mean I just
saw that Kesha is coming out with a
makeup palette oh wow called Kesha Rose
great I was sitting on the toilet I was
like what is this is that Kesha
yeah everyone's coming out so I feel
like for I mean honestly I feel like
it's just like about getting it out
there yeah you know like there are
probably seasons and color changes
obviously but it's like once it's out
its out yeah and I wasn't anticipating
that at all but I'm happy to be amongst
great people yeah it feels like there's
this wave it felt almost like it was
like correlated you guys all were like
here we go right it's like when you wear
the same dress like were you guys
texting yeah we were texting about the
lawn yeah
okay last question what do you miss the
most and the least about Canada I miss
how nice everyone was honestly everyone
is so nice in Canada that's a good
stereotype that so [ __ ] true but I
feel like the thing I missed the least
is living there to be honest I love
going back cuz it makes it more exciting
yeah but it's like if I were to still
live there then I would be more excited
about coming to LA so I like having that
magic my whole family is there yeah and
I just love going back and just seeing
everybody but I feel like the reason I
moved is because I sucked that city dry
yeah well speaking of moves what's next
what's coming up if you can say anything
I can't no it's so annoying things
they're coming Mary okay yes and I
honestly feel like the end of the year
is my favorite time of the year because
it's Christmas
yeah it's wrapping up the whole thing
you get to you know reminisce on the
entire year you've had we've had an
amazing year nots and I and all my
friends my family yeah just really like
you know take time and like tell people
that you love them like my grandpa was
just sick he's better now so it's like
we made it another year yeah but 2020 is
gonna be big and I'm really excited
New Year's plans not yet yeah I kind of
want to have a tacky New Year's and go
to Vegas
oh yeah right that sounds perfect kind
of sounds like a [ __ ] show but fun yeah
that feels like if you commit and that
says no [ __ ]
big crowds all that stuff but I feel
like I just maybe I'm just itching to go
to Vegas maybe not for New Year's
I mean check that edge okay before you
go completely GG everyone that has made
time as a guest on our podcast gets a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
you wait like personalized like you put
a fortune in there that might be you
know something specific to your needs or
wants or who knows oh you hate it good
for you it's like I'm chewy but it is
edible yeah thank God okay sorry I'm the
fortune cookie says well we once heard
that grace said that memory said that
Hannah said that Tyler said that Shane
said that Parris said that Caitlin said
and that Sophia said that not said that
he said she said is a fantastic read huh
meanwhile like drooling my mother's
watering now please repeat that fast ten
times nope I'm gonna call that fortune
cookie out one you don't have to repeat
that and I'm literally trying to make my
friends do this thank you so much for
being here Gigi I'm so excited for
everything that you've been doing where
can people find you and again where can
they find the line and everything that
you're up to so the makeup line is
available exclusively a tipsy calm you
can buy the box like I sent you and
Mamie you beautiful it makes me feel
fancier than I am I mean that makes me
really happy yeah it was I think $200
but now it's down to 40 the box
really yes wait 40 for all the product
yes dad yes just like a limited deal
that's insane I don't know if that's on
right now but go check if you sleep on
that deal you're crazy
no right I saw that and I was like if
see that bunker yeah so I know a lot of
people got the box but you can shop each
product exclusively there if you just
want the blush or the highlighter what
I'm learning I'm Gigi gorgeous
everywhere all over all over all socials
I'm tick-tock Oh get it and I'm that
Gigi gorgeous on Twitter
perfect well thank you so much it is so
fun I can't wait to hear what Paris
Hilton shenanigans you get up to in the
and also I'm sorry for the bruises that
you have endured from her asleep kicking
we'll see you guys next time on not too
deep goodbye to deep toe deep deep deep
whatever struggles you are facing from
depression and anxiety to trauma and
grief better help can connect you with
the professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's so
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and anything
you share is completely confidential
best of all it's an affordable option
and our listeners will get 10% off your
first month with the discount code grace
so why not get started simply go to
better help calm slash grace fill out a
questionnaire and get matched with a
counselor that you'll love today not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
camera operator Katrina Henning edited
by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]